this is a CBS News special report I'm
funded a couple in New York another
Thursday and we've come to you once
again with the newest weekly report on
jobless claims it has just come out and
it shows another huge jump in
unemployment tied to the pandemic so
let's get right to CBS News business
analyst Jill Schlesinger joining us Jill
good morning what are the latest numbers
show an additional 3.8 million Americans
filed for unemployment claims that
brings our six week total to over 30
million Americans it's unbelievable
again this erases all job creation since
the entire recovery sent back to the
financial crisis and I think this is
something that we've got to keep
watching although the numbers are
tapering down a bit this is just an
enormous amount of people we understand
from a recent poll that there's probably
50 percent of Americans who say they
either lost work or hours in this crisis
this jives with an international label
labor organization review tony that
found that 50% of the global workers are
going to find themselves impacted so the
numbers are still way too high
Wow 30 million community as you say
that's a giant number but we keep
hearing reports that people are trying
to file for unemployment and they can't
could there still be more out there who
are unemployed but not yet counted the
left-leaning think-tank in the EP I
found that when they surveyed folks that
people felt warded by the unemployment
claim process they estimate that there
could be somewhere between another 9 and
14 million Americans who have not
successfully claimed benefits that's
astonishing really to imagine there's
that many more people out there who need
to file claims all right and of course
all this happening against the backdrop
of GDP economic output falling in the
first quarter and projections for the
second quarter even worse on the order
of 30 or 40 percent declines in output
Joe Schlessinger we appreciate you
walking us through it the headline again
cumulative unemployment near 30 million
that is roughly the population of Texas
so imagine every man woman and child in
that state
out of work that is the scale that we
are contemplating